The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All right.
Today, we resume our theme of
memory hierarchy efficient data
structures.
And last time, we saw
cache-oblivious b-trees,
which achieve log base B
of N for all operations--
insert, delete, search.
And the cool part is
that we could do that
without knowing what B was.
And it was basically
a binary search tree
stored in a funny order,
this van Emde Boas order,
with an ordered file
on the bottom, which
we left as a black box.
And today, we're
going to see how
to actually do ordered files--
in log squared N, data
moves per insert and delete.
And then as a little
diversion, we'll
see a closer related
problem to this
is called list labeling,
which we needed in Lecture 1
and left it as a black
box for full persistence.
We had this version tree
with full persistence,
and we needed to linearize
that version tree
into a bunch of numbers
so that we could then
compare whether one version
was an ancestor of another.
And for that, we needed to be
able to store a linked list,
and insert and delete
in the linked list,
and be able to query, who is
this node in the linked list,
precede this node
in the linked list
in constant time per operation.
So we'll also do that
today because it's time.
And then we're going to
do a completely different
cache-oblivious data structure.
That's interesting, mainly in
the way that it adapts to M,
not just B. So remember, B was
the size of a memory block.
When we fetch
something from memory,
we get the entire block of size
B. M was the size of the cache.
And so there were M over B
blocks in the cache of size
B. So that's what
we'll do today.
I'm also going to need a claim--
which we won't prove here--
that you can sort
cache-obliviously in N
over B log base N
over B of N over B.
So I'm going to use this
as a black box today.
And we're not going to
fill it in because it's not
a data structure, and it's
a data structures class.
To give you some feeling for
why this is the right bound
for sorting, if
you know M and B,
then the answer is M
over B way mergesort.
So you all know
binary mergesort,
where you split into two parts.
If you split into M
over B parts and then do
an M over B way merge,
that's exactly what
a cache can handle.
It can read one block
from each of the lists
that it's trying to merge.
It has just enough
cache blocks for that.
And then you do the merge
block by block, load new blocks
as necessary.
That will give you
a linear time merge.
And so you'll get N over
B times log base M over B.
And it turns out the right
thing in here is N over B or N
is basically the same,
because it's inside the log.
It's not a big deal.
So external memory wise,
that's how you do it.
You can do this
cache-obliviously in a similar
way to--
roughly speaking, in a
similar way to the way
we do b-trees,
where you're binary
searching in the
number of ways you
should divide your array into.
I'm not going to get
into details on that.
We'll focus on
cache-oblivious priority
queues, which do a similar kind
of thing, but get it a dynamic.
All right.
But before we go there, let's
do ordered file maintenance.
So let me first remind
you of the problem.
We want to store N
items in a file, which
think of as an array, size
order N. This constant's
bigger than 1, with
constant-sized gaps.
And then-- I should
say in specified order,
subject to inserting and
deleting items in that order.
So this was the picture.
We have an array.
We get to store some
objects in the array
and have these blank
cells in between.
But each of these gaps
has constant size.
Maybe these data items
are sorted, maybe not.
And then we're able
to say things like,
OK, insert a new
item 8 right after 7.
And so then you'd
like to do that.
Then you'd also, then, like to
say OK, now insert new item 9,
here.
And then this guy will
maybe get shifted over.
So 12 is over here.
This becomes blank, and then
you can fit the 9, and so on.
You want to be able to do
insertions and deletions
like that quickly.
And quickly, here,
means whenever
we do an insert or delete,
we're going to rearrange items
in an interval.
And that interval is
going to be small--
log squared N amortized.
That's all I need to say here.
I guess we also want
to say that when we're
moving these items
in the interval,
we can do it efficiently
cache-obliviously, because we
really want log
squared N divided by B.
And we say that via constant
number of interleaved scans.
Scans, we know, as long as
there's a number of them
and your cache has at least a
constant size number of blocks,
then interleave scans are
always going to be efficient.
You always get to divide
by B. But the focus
will be on making sure
the interval is small.
The rearrangement will actually
be very simple, so not too hard
to do.
So this will give us log squared
N over B amortized memory
transfers.
So that was the
black box we needed
to get cache-oblivious b-trees.
Remember, we got rid of
the square in the log
by using a level of indirection
that removed one of the logs.
So we got log N
over B. So we were
dominated by log
base B of N, which
is what we had for
the search over here.
So this is the step we need.
And this is a general
tool used in a bunch
of different cache-oblivious
data structures, sort
of one of the first
cache-oblivious data structure
tools.
It's pretty handy.
It's actually much older
than cache-oblivious
or external memory models.
This results-- removing the
last line and this part,
which makes it
efficient in this model.
Just thinking about moving
around intervals in a file
goes back to Itai,
Konheim, and Rodeh in 1981.
So it's pretty old.
And then it was brought to the
cache-oblivious world in 2000,
right when this model
was getting started.
So that's the goal.
Now let me tell you how
this is going to work.
So a rough idea is very simple.
You have your array.
And when you insert an
item, what we want to do
is find an interval
containing that item
of some reasonable
size that's not
too full and not too sparse.
If we can find--
so like right here,
when we're inserting 9,
it looks really bad
right around there.
And so there's, like,
too many elements
packed right around
that element.
And that feels bad to us.
So we grow an interval around
it until we've got enough gaps.
And then we just evenly
redistribute the items
in that interval.
So that's basically
what we're going to do.
We just have to
find the right size
interval to rearrange items in.
Then when we do
the rearrangement,
it's always going to be
evenly redistributing
within the interval.
So that strategy is simple.
And to think about intervals
in a nice controlled way,
we're going to build
a binary tree--
our good friend.
So let me just draw
this binary tree.
Now I need to do
something a little bit
special at the leaves.
I'm going to cluster
together log N items.
So down here is the array,
and all of this stuff
up here is conceptual.
We don't really build it.
In my lecture notes, I
can just copy and paste
and this is a lot easier.
So we have these chunks of
size theta log N at the bottom.
I don't really care
what the constant is.
1 is probably fine.
So this is the array
down here, and we're
splitting every log N items,
or log N cells in the array.
And then we say, OK,
well conceptually build
a binary structure tree, here.
And then this node
represents this interval.
And this node represents
this interval.
Every node just represents the
interval of all its descendant
leaves.
We've seen this trick
over and over again.
But we're not going to
build any data structure
or have some augmentation
for each of these nodes.
This is how we're going
to build the intervals.
We're going to
start at the leaf.
Let's say we want to
insert an item in here.
So we insert it here.
If there's not room for it,
we're going to walk up the tree
and say, OK, if this
interval is too dense,
I'll look at this node and
its corresponding interval
here to here.
If that's still too dense,
I'll walk up to the parent,
and so look at this
interval from here to here,
and so on, until I find
that in the end, at most,
I redistribute the entire array.
And when I do that, I'll
just evenly redistribute.
Let me write down the
algorithm for update.
So for insert or
delete, same algorithm,
you update the leaf log N chunk.
You can do that just by
rewriting the entire chunk.
We're trying to get a
log squared N bound,
so we can afford to
rewrite it interval as size
log N. So that's for free.
So whatever leaf
contains the element
you want to insert or delete.
And then we're going to
walk up the tree until we
find a suitable interval.
And we're going to call
that node, or that interval,
within threshold.
So let me define
We're going to look at
the density of a node,
or an interval.
And that's just going to be the
ratio of the number of elements
that are actually down there
versus the amount of slots
in the array that
are down there--
so just how much is occupied.
So look at that ratio.
If it's 100%, then there are
no blank cells down there.
If it's 0%, then
everybody is blank.
So we don't want either
of those extremes.
We want something in between.
And we're going to do that
by specifying thresholds
on this density and
try to keep the density
within those thresholds.
Let me let me define
those thresholds.
The fun part is that the density
thresholds that you maintain
depend on which level you are.
Not, like, experience points,
but in which height of the tree
you are.
So down here, we don't really
care how well-distributed
the leaves are.
I mean, it can't
be 0% because then
that would be a really big gap.
But it could be say
between 50% and 100%.
It could be totally full.
And then once it's overflowing,
then we've got to go up.
And the higher we go,
the stricter we get--
hopefully, yes-- strictest
at the top of the tree.
So in general, if we have
a node of the depth, d,
then we want the density
to be at least 1/2
minus 1/4 d over h.
And we want the density to be at
most 3/4 plus 1/4 d over it h.
So h, here, is the height
of this tree, which
is going to be something
like log N minus log-log N.
But it doesn't really matter.
This is depth 0,
depth 1, depth h.
We just are linearly
interpolating between--
let's see, this is always
between 1/4 and 1/2--
1/2 when this is 0,
1/4 when this is h.
So you get a 1/2 minus 1/4.
And this one is always
in the range 3/4 to 1.
It's 3/4 when this is
0, and 1 when this is h.
So at the bottom--
I was a little bit off.
At the bottom, the leaf
level, when these are both h--
the density has to be at
least a 1/4 and at most, 100%.
And then at the root,
it's going to have
to be between 1/2 and 3/4.
So it's a narrower range.
And the higher you go up,
the more narrow the range
on the density gets.
And we do it just sort of in
the obvious linear interpolation
way.
The not so obvious thing is that
this is the right way to do it.
There's a lot of choices
for how to set these density
thresholds.
But we have to basically
maintain constant density
everywhere because
we're trying to maintain
gaps of constant size.
So we don't have a
lot of flexibility.
But it turns out,
this flexibility
between two constants,
like 1/4 and 1/2
is enough to give us
the performance we need.
So let's see why.
Let me finish this algorithm.
We walk up the tree
until reaching a node
within threshold.
Density is this.
Density threshold is this.
So now we know within
threshold means.
And then we evenly
rebalance or redistribute
all the descendant
elements in that interval
that is within threshold.
So what you need to
check is that you
can do this with a
constant number of scans.
It's not that hard.
Just read the elements in order.
Write them out to
a temporary array,
and then write them back.
Or if you're fancy,
you can do it in place.
But you can just do it by
a constant number of scans
through the array.
Just compute what should
be the average gap
between the elements.
Leave that many gaps.
So the algorithm
is pretty simple
once you say, OK, I'm
going to grow intervals.
Then maybe, you think OK,
I guess I'll grow intervals
according to a binary tree.
It's a little bit
more controlled.
Probably don't have
to do it this way.
You could just grow
them by a factor of 2,
just around your point.
But it's easier to analyze in
the setting of a binary tree.
And then once you're doing
that, the tricky part
is to set the
density thresholds.
But you fool around
and this seems
to be the best way to do it.
Now the question is,
why does this work.
How do we prove log squared
amortized interval size when we
follow these dense thresholds?
Notice that we're
not keeping intervals
within density at all times.
I mean, the whole problem
is that things are not
within threshold
right at the start.
And we have to walk up the tree
quite a ways, potentially--
claim is only about log-log
N levels up the tree--
to find something
that's within density.
And then we can redistribute.
And then we fix
everything below us.
All right.
Well, let's get to that.
This is really the
direction we want.
The thresholds are getting
tighter and tighter,
more constrained as we go up.
Because it means if
we walk up a lot,
we, essentially, can pay for it
because we bring that interval
even farther within threshold.
So we have some node,
which is within threshold.
So we bring it into the
density thresholds of here.
If we look at the
children of that node,
their density
thresholds are smaller--
sorry, are more relaxed.
So if we bring this
node into threshold
by rewriting all the
leaves down here,
these nodes will not
only be within threshold,
they'll be far within threshold.
If you look at their ratios,
you know, their densities--
the number of elements in there,
divided by the array slots.
It's going to be
exactly the same.
The density is equal
because we're uniformly
distributing the items here.
And there's some
rounding errors,
but other than rounding.
And that's actually why we have
these leaves as size theta log
N, so the rounding
doesn't bite us.
We're evenly redistributing
so the density is equal
everywhere.
Left child had the same
density as the parent.
But if you look at the density
thresholds of the child,
they will be more relaxed
compared to the parent.
So if the parent is
within threshold,
the child will be
far within threshold
by at least a d over
h additive amount.
Sorry, 1 over h, because
their depths differ by 1.
If this is d, this
would be d plus 1.
When we rebalance a
node, we put the children
far within threshold.
Meaning, if we look at
the absolute difference
between the density and
either the upper threshold
or the lower threshold, that
will be, I guess, at least 1
over 4h because we're
increasing d by 1.
And it's 1 over for 4h
for each step we take.
OK so the children
are extra happy.
We walked up here
because before--
let's say we walked
up this path.
So we walked from
the right child.
We didn't stop here,
which means this node was
was beyond threshold.
But now we walked up and now
we fixed this entire interval.
And now it's far
within threshold.
So before, you know, the
density minus the threshold
went the wrong way,
had the wrong sign.
Now we're good, and we're
good by at least a 1 over 4h.
Now h, here, was the
height of the tree.
It's log N minus log-log N. All
we need is that this is theta
log N--
sorry, theta 1 over log
N. h is theta log N.
And this is a ratio--
1 over log N--
of the number of items
versus the number of slots.
But we know the
number of slots we're
dealing with is theta log N. And
so this is at least one item.
This log N is designed
to balance the h, here.
OK, cool.
Let's go over here.
So the idea is if we're
far within threshold,
we can charge to those items.
That's our goal.
What we're interested
in-- if we just
rebalanced this node, say x.
We want to know when is the
next time x can be rebalanced?
For x to have to be
rebalanced, that means,
again, one of its children will
have to be out of threshold.
And then we insert or
delete within that child.
And then that
propagates up to x.
But right now, the children
are far within threshold.
So the question is,
how long would it
take for them to get
out of threshold again?
Well, you'd have to change
the density by at least 1
over an additive--
1 over log N. If you
multiply by the size,
it's the size of
the interval divided
by log N. You've got to have
at least that many insertions
or deletions.
Before this node rebalances
again, one of its children
must get out of balance.
And so you must have
done at least the size
of the interval
divided by theta log N
updates for one of the children
to become out of balance again.
Boom.
So when this rebalance
happens again,
we're going to charge to
those updates, which is good
because the time it takes
us to do the rebalance
is the size of the interval.
We need to charge each of
these items log N times.
So charge the
rebalance cost, which
is the size of the
interval to these updates.
And what we know
is that the updates
are within the interval.
So this looks like a log N
bound, which is not right.
It should be a log
squared N bound.
The idea is when we insert
into one of these leaves,
we're simultaneously making this
node worse and this node worse
and this node worse.
Whenever we insert
a node, it belongs
to log N intervals
that we care about.
So in fact, not only
are we losing this log
N, because there aren't quite
enough items to charge to--
the log N factor less.
We're also charging to each item
another factor of log N times
because it lives in all
these different intervals.
Each update gets charged at
most, h, which is order log
N times.
We looked at what
happens for node x,
but we have to apply this
argument simultaneously
for all nodes x.
Fortunately, this
node versus this node,
they don't share
any descendants.
And so there's no
multiple charging.
But node x and its
parent and grandparent
and all its
ancestors, they're all
talking about the same nodes.
And so they will
multiple charge,
but only by a factor
of log N. That's
something we've seen a few
times, charging log N times,
for every node in the
tree, like range trees
having N log N space
in two dimensions.
Same deal.
So we've got size of the
interval divided by log N guys
to charge to, which we multiply
charge log N times, so we get
a log squared amortized bound.
So this log N is hard to avoid
because we have a binary tree
that's pretty natural.
This log N, essentially,
comes from this h.
The fact that we can only
go from one constant factor
to another.
And we've got log N
different steps to make.
We have to do 1 over log
N increment every step.
That's the best we could afford.
That's why these are evenly
spaced out in this linear way.
But if we had a little more
space, we could do better.
So that's going to lead us to
this list labeling problem.
But first, are
there any questions
about order file maintenance?
At this point, we are done.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain again
how is it that you get from
the size of the interval
[INAUDIBLE] and that each--
ERIK DEMAINE: This amortization?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, how you
got to the amortized.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
So let me explain again.
So when we do rebalance
of an interval,
the cost is the size
of the interval.
We're trying to analyze, what
is the size the interval?
Prove that is log
squared N. So we have
this cost of size of interval.
We're charging it to the
items which just got inserted
or deleted into that interval.
Before this node rebalances
again, but in general,
we're interested in the--
we can afford to rebalance
every node at the beginning.
And then whenever
a node rebalances--
before it rebalances,
one of its children
had to be out of whack.
For one of its children
to be out of whack,
there had to have
been an insertion
of at least the size of the
interval divided by log N,
because log was h.
There's a slight
discrepancy, here.
We're talking about
the size of the parent
interval versus the size
of the child interval,
but that's just a factor of 2.
So that's incorporated
by this theta.
So you could have a little
theta here, too, if you like.
OK, so for the child
to be out of whack,
we had to have done updates of
size interval divided by log N.
So we charge this cost to them.
And so we have to charge log
N to each of those items,
each of those updates.
And then there's
a second problem,
which is everybody gets charged
by all of its ancestors.
And it has log N ancestors.
So in all, each update gets
charged at most log squared N
times.
So you get amortized
log squared per update.
Other questions?
Cool.
So that's ordered files.
Now we have b-trees.
We can handle this log squared
N. That was OK for B trees,
using a layer of indirection.
But it's natural to wonder
whether you can do better.
In general, the conjecture
is that for ordered files,
you cannot do better.
If this is your problem
setup, if you can only
have constant sized gaps,
you need a linear size array.
You need log squared
N interval updates,
but no one's proved
that lower bound.
So that's one open question.
Another fun fact is
we did amortized,
but it's actually
possible to do worst case.
It's complicated.
Willard did it in 1992.
But let's talk about
relaxing the problem.
So instead of saying, well, the
array has to be linear size,
what if we let it to be bigger?
And then you can do better.
And this is a problem
called list labeling.
So I'm going to rephrase it,
but it's essentially the same
as order file maintenance.
It's a little bit
less restriction.
So it's a dynamic
linked list problem,
like we've seen before.
And each node at all
times stores a label such
that labels are always
monotone down the list.
So think of it this way.
We have a linked list.
And all we're interested is
maintaining this linked list.
So we want to be able to
say, OK, delete this item
and update these pointers.
Or maybe, insert a
new item over here.
And so it's going to
be linked like that.
And at all times in
this cell here, we're
storing a number, 3, 7,
12, 14, 42, whatever.
It could be any
integer, let's say.
And we need that the
numbers are increasing order
down the linked list.
Now, I claim this is basically
the same as an ordered file
problem.
Just think of this number as
being the index in the array
that you store it.
So this should be
strictly monotone--
I guess, increasing
down the list.
That means none of these
numbers are the same.
So we can store the items--
whatever data is
associated with this node--
we can store that in
the array position 3,
in the array position 7,
in the array position 12.
When we insert, we have to find
a new label between 3 and 7.
Now we're allowed to change
the labels dynamically--
that's what makes
this possible--
which corresponds to
moving items in the array.
And the only difference is about
how this is physically done.
With ordered file, you have
to physically move items
in the array.
Here, you just change a number
and that's moving the item.
Where this gets interesting is
if you allow the label space--
which is the storage
space of the array--
to become super linear.
With ordered files, it doesn't
really make a lot of sense
to go super linear, at least,
not by more than a couple log
factors because time is
always at least space.
If you have a giant array,
you have to initialize it.
And you can't afford to
initialize an array of, say,
N squared size, if you're
trying to maintain N items.
But in list labeling, you can.
I mean, if you say all these
numbers are between 0 and N
squared, that's no
big deal because you
can represent a number up to
N squared, which is two log N
bits.
So squaring the space is no
big deal for list labeling.
It would be a big deal for
order file maintenance,
so that's why we rephrase.
But they're basically
the same problem--
just a little less useful
for cache-oblivious stuff.
Let me tell you what's
known about mislabelling.
In terms of the amount of
label space you're given,
and how good a running
time per update
we can get, in terms
of best known results.
So what we just saw
is that if you do--
we just said linear space.
But in fact, you can get
1 plus epsilon space.
You can say, oh, I wouldn't want
to waste 1% of my storage space
in the array.
And if you set the
theta at the leaves,
here, to the right value,
then you can just waste 1%
and still maintain
an ordered file.
I think this is cool from
a file system perspective.
But in particular, it
gives us what we need.
And if you go up
to N log N space,
it doesn't seem
to help you much.
The best we know is log
squared N. As I mentioned,
it could be amortized
or worst case.
If you bump up the space to
N to the 1 plus epsilon--
so a little bit super linear--
and anything polynomial, then
the best we know is log N.
And there is actually
a lower bound
for this result in
a particular model.
So it seems pretty clear that--
at least for these style
of data structures,
the best you can do in
this situation is log N.
But hey, log N is
better than log squared.
And the other obvious bound is
if you have exponential space,
you can do constant,
essentially.
Because with
exponential space, you
can just keep
bisecting the interval
between two items
in constant time
until you've inserted N items.
And then you can rebuild
the whole data structure.
So that's sort of
the trivial result.
If you don't care about
how big these labels get--
and how big they would
get is 2 to the N--
then you can do constant time.
That's really the only way
we know how to do constant.
So the interesting
new result, here,
that I'm talking about
is for polynomial space,
we can get log N.
And rough idea is you just
fixed these density intervals.
Now you don't have to make it--
I mean, you're still going
to be divided by h, here,
but your spread
can be much bigger.
So your densities no longer
have to be constants.
Now we can afford a density--
near the root, we can get
a density of like 1 over--
actually, anywhere, we
can afford a density of 1
over N. Because if we have N
squared slots and only N items
to put in them, then a decent
density is 1 over N, in fact.
It could also be constant.
Constant would be all right.
So we've got a big spread there,
from 1 over N to constant.
And so we can afford to
take much bigger jumps here,
of like 1 over N. And so that
gets rid of this log N factor,
essentially.
That was the rough sketch.
I have written, here,
that the densities we use
are no longer uniformly spaced.
The 1 over alpha to the d.
Alpha, here, is some constant
in the interval between 1 and 2.
And d is the depth.
So now we have exponentially
increasing densities
which give you a big gap--
no longer lose
this log N factor.
So you do exactly the
same data structure,
these different densities.
Now you've got room to
fill in a whole bunch
more densities when you
have, say, N squared space.
And so you only get the log N
factor because of the number
of ancestors of a node.
And you lose the
other log N factor.
Now let me tell you
about another problem
building on this.
So this is the list order
maintenance problem.
And this is the problem
we saw in a Lecture 1.
So here, same as before,
maintain a linked list,
subject to, insert a
node at this location,
delete a node at this
location, and order queries.
Is node x before
node y in the list?
This is what we needed to
support full persistence.
You have a big linked list.
And then if I give you
this node and this node,
I want to know that this
node is before that node
in the list in constant time.
I claim that we can solve this
problem given our solutions
to list labeling--
not so obvious, how.
List labeling is
great because it lets
you do order queries, right?
You just compare the two
labels and you instantly
discover which is before which.
And so if we could afford
log N time over there,
we could just use this solution.
And this is reasonable.
But we really want constant
time per operation.
Now if we do constant
time per operation
and we use exponential
label space,
this is not so good
because it means you need
N bits to write down a label.
So it's going to take,
like, linear time to modify
or to compare two labels.
This doesn't save you.
We can afford to do this.
This is only log
N bits per label.
And we assume all
of our integers
can store at least log N bits--
something called
a Word RAM Model.
And so we can afford
to store these labels,
but we pay this log N time.
So you've got to
remove a log N factor.
How do we do that?
Indirection-- just
like last class.
Let's do that on this board.
On the top, we're going to
store N over log N items
using this list labeling with
label space, say, N squared.
Any polynomial will do.
And so this takes
log N per operation
to do anything on these
N over log N items.
And then at the
bottom, we have lots
of little structures
of size log N.
And that's supposed to eat up
a factor of log N in our update
time if we do it right.
Actually, I can just do list
labeling down here as well.
So if I'm only
storing log N items,
then I can afford to use
the exponential solution--
the trivial thing where I just
bisect all the labels until all
the log items have changed.
Then, rewrite them.
Because 2 to the log N is only
N. So here, in each of these,
I do a list labeling with
space 2 to the log N,
also known as N.
So these guys are constant
time to do anything in
to maintain the labels.
And to maintain levels up here--
so to maintain, basically, each
of these N over log N guys,
is one representative element
representing this entire group
as N over log N of these groups.
So this label
structure is supposed
to distinguish the
different groups.
And then the labels in here
are distinguishing the items
within the group.
Now this cost log N amortized
to keep what we need up here.
But now if I want
the label of an item,
I just take this label,
comma, this label.
So if I have an item
here, for example,
at first, I look at
the label of this block
as stored by this
data structure.
And then I look at the
label within the block.
And so my composite
label is going
to be an ordered pair of top
label, comma, the bottom label.
This is kind of funny
because it looks
like we're solving the list
labeling problem again,
with now a space of N cubed.
We've got N squared for
the first coordinate,
and then N for the
second coordinate.
So if you just
concatenate those two
labels, that lives in a bigger
label space of size N cubed.
And yet, I claim this
takes constant amortized
and is not a solution
to list labeling.
It's just a matter of, again,
how updates are performed.
With order file maintenance, we
had to physically move items.
With list labeling
problem, we had
to modify the number
stored with each node.
That's expensive.
In this world, if we
change a label up here,
we are basically
instantly-- say,
we changed the label
corresponding to this group
in here.
We changed the label all of
these items in one operation.
Or actually, it
takes log N time.
And then we change the label
of all log N of these items.
So that's why we get
constant amortized.
So how does this work?
If we insert a new
item, we stick it
into one of these blocks.
The block that it fits into.
If this block gets too full,
more than, say, 1 times log N,
then we split it in half.
If it gets too sparse by
deletion, say, less than a 1/4
log N, then we'll merge it
with one of its neighbors,
and then possibly split.
Each of those triggers a
constant number of operations
up here.
And so we pay log N,
but we only pay it
when we've made theta log N
changes to one of these blocks.
So we can charge this log N
cost to those log N updates.
And so this turns into constant.
This down here is
always constant.
And so it's constant amortized.
And if each of these
blocks remembers
what the corresponding--
and, basically, this
is a linked list, here.
And then we have
linked list down here,
and they have labels.
And it's like a, what do you
call, a skip list with just two
levels.
And every node
here just remembers
what its parent is up here.
So if you want to know
your composite label,
you just look at the bottom
label and then walk up.
Look at the top label.
Those are just stored
right there in the nodes.
And so in constant time,
you can find your top label,
your bottom label.
Therefore, you can compare
two items in constant time.
So this solves the problem
we needed in Lecture 1.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, why isn't it
the same as the N cubed label
space?
ERIK DEMAINE: OK.
Why is it not same as N cubed
label space, which I claim
has a lower amount of log N?
The difference is
with list labeling,
you have to explicitly change
the label of each items.
And here, we're
basically computing
the label of a node now becomes
a constant time algorithm.
We're allowed to
look at the label,
here, then walk up, then
look at the label, here.
And by changing
the label up here,
we change it simultaneously
for log N guys down there.
So that's the big difference
between this list order
maintenance problem from
the list labeling problem.
These were actually all
solved in the same paper
by Dietz and Slater.
But sort of successively--
slightly relaxing
on a problem makes
a huge difference in the
running time you can achieve.
Obviously, we can't get
any better than constant.
So we're done in--
of course, then there's
external memory versions--
but in terms of regular
data structures.
And again, Willard made
it worst case constant.
That's a lot harder.
Other questions?
Cool.
So that does order file
maintenance and list labeling.
And so next, we're going to
move to a very different data
structure, which is
cache-oblivious priority queue.
We haven't really done
any cache-oblivious data
structures, yet.
So it's time to return
to our original goal.
We're not actually going
to use ordered files.
Sadly, that was last lecture.
So All of this was a
continuation of last lecture.
Now we're going to do a
different data structure.
It's going to adapt
to B, it's going
to adapt to M. It's
cache-oblivious.
And it achieves priority queue.
Now remember, this
sorting bound--
N over B log base M of N over
B This is our sorting bound.
Then the priority queue bound
we want is this divided by N.
So we want to be able to
do 1 over B log base M
over B, N over b.
Insert and delete
min, let's say.
And this is an interesting
bound because it's usually
much less than 1.
It's a sub constant bound.
This is going to
be a little o of 1,
assuming this log is
smaller than this B.
So it's a little o of
1 if, let's say, B is
bigger than the log N, roughly.
This would, in
particular, be enough.
No pun intended-- be enough.
So if our block size
is reasonably big--
cache line is bigger
than log N, which
is probably most likely
in typical caches
and architectures--
then this is more like 1
over B, never mind the log.
And so we have to do B
operations in one step.
And then to really
get the log right,
we have to depend
on M, not just B.
As I mentioned, that's the
bound we're going to achieve.
We do need to make an
assumption about M and B
and how they relate.
So we're going to assume a
tall cache, which is M is,
let's say, B to
the 1 plus epsilon.
So it has to be substantially
bigger than B, not
by a huge amount.
It could be B squared.
It could be B to the 1.1 power.
But M is definitely
at least B. And I want
it to be a little bit bigger.
I want the number of
blocks to be not so tiny.
Here's how we do it.
I think I need a big picture.
So the kind of funny thing about
cache-oblivious priority queues
is we're not going to use trees.
It's basically a bunch of
arrays in a linear order.
In some ways, it's an
easier data structure.
But it's definitely
more complicated.
But, hey, it's
faster than b-trees.
If you don't need to be able
to do searches-- if you just
need to be able to delete
min, then priority queues
are a lot faster than b-trees.
Let me draw this.
I want to try to draw
this pseudo-accurate size.
The only part that's
inaccurate about this picture
is the dot dot dots.
Lets me cheat a little.
So we have x to that
9/4, x to the 3/2 and x.
This is sort of what the
levels are going to look like.
So we have a linear
sequence of levels.
They are increasing doubly
exponentially in size.
If you look at what's
going on here--
double exponential--
AUDIENCE: Are those
exponentials the same as those?
Or are they inverted?
ERIK DEMAINE: It's
supposed to be this--
so this is the top level,
and this is the bottom level.
So at the top, we're going
to have something of size N.
And at the bottom, we're going
to have something of a size C,
constant.
And what I've drawn is
the generic middle part.
So we go from x, to x
to 3/2, to x to the 9/4.
Or you could say x to the
9/4, down to x to the 3/2,
down to x, according to
this exponential geometric
progression, I guess.
So that's how they go.
So I mean, if it was
just exponential,
it would be, like, N,
N over 2, N over 4.
But we're doing--
in logarithms, we're
changing by constant factors.
So it's doubly exponential.
And then each of the
levels is decomposed
into top buffers and bottom--
or, sorry, up buffers
and down buffers.
And as you see, the
size of the top buffer
is equal to the sum of the
sizes of the bottom buffers.
So let me elaborate
on how this works.
It's level x to the 3/2.
We're going to, generically,
be looking at x to the 3/2.
So I can easily go down.
That's of size x.
And up is x to the 9/4--
easily.
There's always one up
buffer of size x to the 3/2.
So maybe some color.
So this buffer, here,
is x to the 3/2.
And then we also have up to x
to the 1/2 down buffers, each
of size theta x.
Each of these guys
has size theta x.
And then the number of them
is, at most, x to the 1/2.
And so you take
the product, that's
x to 3/2, which is the
same as the up buffer.
So that's the way
this cookie crumbles.
That's how each of these guys
decomposes into little pieces.
And so, in particular, this
up buffer, if you work it out,
should be exactly the same
size as this down buffer.
Maybe it's easier
to do these two.
So this down buffer has size x.
And if you have a structure size
x, the up buffer has size x.
x of 3/2 has an up
buffer size of x 3/2.
So this will be size x.
And so these match.
These are equal size.
That's why I drew it this way.
Now the dot dot dot hides the
fact that they're x to the 1/2
of these.
So there's a lot
of down buffers.
They're actually a lot
smaller than up buffers.
But these two match in
size and these two match
in size, and so on.
OK, there's a small exception.
I'd put theta x here.
The exception is that the
very first down buffer
might be mostly empty.
So this one is not
actually data x.
Each of these will be theta x.
And this one over on the
left will be big O of x.
Small typo in the notes, here.
So if that's not sufficiently
messy, let me redraw it--
make it a little cleaner.
I want to look at two
consecutive levels
and specify invariants.
So after all, I'm trying to
maintain a priority queue.
What the heck is this thing?
The idea is that
towards the bottom,
that's where the min is.
That would seem good,
because at the bottom,
you're constant size.
I can diddle with the
thing of constant size
if fits in a block
or if it's in cache.
It takes me zero time to
touch things near the bottom.
So as long as I always
keep the min down there,
I can do fine min in zero time.
And delete min will
also be pretty fast.
I'm also going to insert
there, because I don't
know where else to put it.
I'd like the larger items
to be at near the top.
I'd like the smaller items
to be near the bottom,
but kind of hard to know,
when I insert an item,
where it belongs.
So I'll just start by
inserting at the bottom.
And the idea is as I insert,
insert, insert down here,
things will start to trickle up.
That's what the up arrows mean,
that these items are moving up.
And then down arrow items are
items that are moving down.
Somehow this is going to work.
So let me tell
you the invariants
that will make this work.
If you look at the down
buffers, they are sorted.
Or I should say, all
the items in here
are less than all the
items in here, and so on.
But within each down
buffer, it's disordered.
Then we also know this.
All the items in the up
buffer in a given level--
this is x to the 3/2, let's say.
And this is x.
All of the up items are larger
than all of the down items.
I mean, it's just
an inequality here.
So these guys are
basically in a chain.
Again, the items in
here are not sorted.
But all the items here are
bigger than all the items here
are bigger than all
of the items here are
bigger than all the items here.
Now what about from
level to level?
This is a little more subtle.
What we know is this.
So again, we know that all
the down buffers are sorted.
And we know that
this down buffer,
all these items come before
all this down buffer items.
But these up buffer
items, we don't know yet,
because they're still moving up.
Now we know this.
They need to move up.
But we still don't
know how far up.
We don't know how these
items compare to these items.
Or these items could
have to go higher,
could be they belong here,
or are here, who knows.
So basically, the down buffers
are more or less sorted.
And so the mins are going
to be down at the bottom.
And the up buffer items, I
mean, they're still moving up.
We don't know where
they belong, yet.
But eventually they'll
find their place
and start trickling down.
Roughly speaking, an item
will go up for a while
and then come back down.
Although, that's
not literally true.
It's roughly true.
I should say something
about how we actually
store this in memory, because
the whole name of the game
is how you lay
things out in memory.
In cache-oblivious, that's all
you get to choose, basically.
The rest is algorithm,
regular RAM algorithm.
And all we do is store
the items in order,
say, from bottom to top.
So store the entire C
level, then the next level
up, to store these items
as consecutive arrays.
That's what we need to.
Leave enough space for x to
the 1/2 down buffers, each
at size theta x.
So how do we do
inserts and deletes?
Let's start with insert.
As I mentioned, we want to start
by inserting in the bottom,
until we run out of
room in the bottom.
And then things
have to trickle up.
So here's the basic algorithm.
You look at the bottom level.
You stick the item
into the up buffer.
This is not necessarily
the right thing to do.
So here, you stick it
into the up buffer.
But these things are supposed
to be roughly sorted.
So once you stick it there,
you say, oh, well maybe I
have to go down here.
Go down here.
The point is the up
buffer is the only one
I want to be growing in size.
So I insert into the up buffer.
And say, oh, potentially
I have to swap down here.
Swap down here.
I mean, this is constant size.
I can afford to look at all
the items here in zero time
and find out which
buffer it belongs to.
As I move the item
down here, I swap.
So I take the max item here
and move it up to here.
Move the max item from
the next down buffer
and propagate it up, so that
I keep these things in order.
Swap into bottom down
buffers if necessary--
or maybe, as necessary.
You might have to
do a bunch of swaps.
But it's all constant.
And then the point
is the only buffer
that got larger by one item was
the up buffer, because, here,
we did swaps to preserve size.
And if that overflows, then
we do something interesting.
And something interesting
is called push.
This is a separate team,
which I'll define now.
So this is the
bottom level push.
But I wanted to find the
generic level of push, which
is we're going to be pushing
x elements into level x
to the 3/2.
So why is that?
Check it out.
If we're at level x and
our up buffer overflows,
and we're trying to push
into the next level--
that's level x to 3/2--
then the up buffer that we're
trying to push has size x.
The up buffer has the same
size as the level name.
So if we're at level
x, this has size x.
We're trying to push x items
up into the next thing.
We're going to empty
out the up buffer.
Send all those items up there.
Cool.
So what do we do?
How do we do this push?
First thing we do
is sort the items--
those x items.
This is where I need
the black box, which
is that we can sort
N over B log base N
over B, N over B
cache-obliviously.
So we're going to use that here.
It's not hard, but I don't
want to spend time on it.
Now the interesting bit
is how we do the push.
The tricky part is we
have all these items,
we know that they're bigger
than all the items below them.
Maybe, here's a better picture.
We know these guys
need to go up.
They're bigger than everything,
all the down items below us.
But we don't know,
does it fit here?
Here?
Or here?
But we do know that
these things are ordered.
And so if we sort these
items, then we can say,
well, let's start
by looking here.
Do any of these items
fit in this block?
Just look at the max, here.
And if these guys are
smaller than the max, here,
then they belong here.
So keep inserting there.
Eventually, we'll get bigger
than the max, then we go here.
Look at the max item, here.
As long as we have items here
that are smaller than the max
here, insert, insert,
insert, insert, and so on.
And then when we're beyond
all of these-- maybe
we're immediately
beyond all of these.
We have to check, oh,
bigger than the max,
bigger than the max.
Then we put all the remaining
items into the up buffer.
This is called distribution.
So we're looking at
level x to the 3/2,
and just scanning sequentially.
Because we just sorted them,
we're scanning them in order.
We visit the down
buffers in order.
And insert into the appropriate
down buffer as we go.
Now there's a little bit
that can happen, here.
Our down buffers
have a limit in size.
Down buffers are supposed to
have size theta x at level
x the 3/2.
So as we're inserting into here,
a down buffer might overflow.
I've got theta slop, here.
So when a down buffer overflows,
I just split it in half.
I then make two down buffers.
Well, actually,
it would be, like,
here and right next to it.
I'm going to maintain a
linked list of down buffers.
And each of them will have
space for say, 2x items.
But once I do a split,
they'll both be half full.
So when a down buffer
overflows, split in half
and maintain a linked
list of down buffers.
Another thing that can happen
is when you increase the number
down buffers, we have a limit
on how many down buffers
we can have--
up to x the 1/2 of them.
So if we run out of down
buffers by splitting,
then we need to start
using the up buffer.
So maybe here, we split,
maybe, this buffer--
is now too many
down buffers total.
Then we'll just take
all the elements in here
and stick them into the
up buffer, because that's
where they belong.
So when the number
of down buffers
is too big, when that
number overflows,
move the last down buffer
into the up buffer.
So there's basically two
ways that elements are going
to get into the up buffer.
One way is that we run
out of down buffers,
and so the last down
buffer starts getting
promoted into the up buffer.
The other possibility
is that we're
inserting items that are
just really big in value.
And if the items
that are getting
promoted from here
into the next level
just happen to be larger
than all these items,
we will immediately start
inserting into the up buffer.
But in general, we have to
look at this down buffer.
Look at this one.
Look at this one, then that one.
That is insert and push.
I think before I
talk about delete,
I'd like to talk about the
analysis of just insert
and push.
Keep it simple.
And then I'll briefly
tell you about deletion.
Oh, I didn't say.
Sorry.
There's one more step,
which is the recursion.
Running out a room, here.
Maybe I'll go over here.
This is nothing relevant.
So I need to recurse somehow.
At some point, inserting things
into the up offer, the up
buffer might overflow.
That's the one last thing
that could overflow.
When that happens, I just
push it to the next level up.
So as we do
insertions in here, we
might start inserting
a lot into here.
Eventually, this
will get too big.
It's supposed to
have size x the 3/2.
If it gets bigger than
that, take all these items
and just recursively push
them up to the next level.
And conveniently, that's
exactly the same size
as we were doing before.
Here, we did x into
level x to the 3/2.
Next will be x to the 3/2 into
level x to the 9/4, and so on.
Always the size
of the up buffer.
So the claim is if we
look at the push at level
x to the 3/2--
which is what we
just described--
and we ignore the recursion.
Then the cost is x over B log
base M over B of x over B--
so sorting bound on x items.
So we spend that right away
in the very first step.
We sort x items.
So that costs x over B. It has
log base M over B of x over B.
And the whole point
of the analysis
is to show that this
distribution step doesn't cost
any more than the sorting step.
So let's prove this claim.
And the first
observation-- maybe,
don't even need to
write this down.
So remember, with
cache-oblivious b-trees,
we looked at a
level of detail that
was sort of the
relevant one that
straddled B. Now we
have this data structure
and there's no longer recursive
levels in this picture.
It's just a list.
But one of the things
we said is that if you
look at the very
small structures,
those are free because
they just stay in cache.
I'm going to assume--
it's a little bit of a
bastardization of notation--
assume that all the levels
up to M fit in cache.
It's really up to, like,
size M over 2 or something,
but let's just call it all.
If x is less than
M, then you know
all this stuff has size order
M. And so let's just say--
by redefining what M is
by a constant factor--
that just fits in cache.
Because we can assume
whatever cache replacement
strategy we want,
assume that these things
stay in cache forever.
So all of that bottom
stuff, size up to M,
is permanently in cache
and costs zero to access.
So those levels are for free.
So it's all about when we
touch the upper levels.
And, really, the
most important level
would be the transition
from the things that
fit in cache to the next level
up that does not fit in cache.
That's going to
be the key level.
But in general,
let's look at push.
Or let's just assume x to
the 3/2 is bigger than M.
Because we're looking at a
push at level x to the 3/2.
And just by definition, if
it's less than M, it's free.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So how can
you assume that all
of the things below
that particular size
always stay in cache empty?
So you're making assumptions
on the cache replacement?
ERIK DEMAINE: I'm
making assumption
on the cache replacement
strategy, which I actually
made last lecture.
So I said, magically
assume that we
use optimal cache replacement.
So whatever I choose, opt is
going to be better than that.
So you're right.
The algorithm doesn't get to
choose what stays in cache.
But for analysis purposes,
I can say well, suppose
all these things stay in cache.
If I prove an upper
bound in that world,
then the optimal
replacement will do better.
And the LRU or FIFO
replacement will
do within a constant
factor of that,
again, by changing M
by a constant factor.
So I'm freely throwing away
constant factors in my cache
size, but then I will get
that these effectively
stay in cache.
FIFO or LRU will do that just
as well, or almost as well.
Good question.
So now we can just look at
the pushes above that level.
And I really want to look
at this transition level,
but we're going to have
to look at all of them.
So let's do this.
Now I also have tall
cache assumption.
M is at least B to
the 1 plus epsilon.
I actually want a somewhat
bigger assumption,
which is that M is greater
than or equal to B squared.
If it's not B squared,
you have to change
this 3/2 and 9/4 and stuff
to be something a little bit
bigger than 1.
And it gets really messy
to write that down.
So this data structure with
appropriate modification
does work for other
tall cache assumptions,
but let's just assume this one.
So this means M over B
is at least B. That's
sort of the clean statement.
It's true for most caches also,
but this will be my assumption.
OK.
Cool.
So if we just do some algebra.
Claim is this is x is
greater than B to the 4/3.
So that's just taking
this inequality,
x the 3/2 is greater than
or equal to B squared
and raising to
the exponent, 2/3.
And so this turns
into x and this
turns into B to the 2 times
2/3, which would be the 4/3.
So x is quite a
bit bigger than B.
In particular, this means that
x over B is bigger than 1,
by a lot.
But if we take ceiling's
on this, no big deal.
So we don't have to
worry about the ceilings.
All right.
Now the claim is that the
distribution step costs--
this is really the
interesting part--
x over B plus x to the
1/2 memory transfers.
OK.
Why?
Remember, up here we have
x to 1/2 down buffers
that we're looking at.
And we're visiting
them in order.
We touch this down buffer.
And really, we just care
about the max, here.
And then we start writing
elements one by one.
But if we write
elements one by one,
the very first element we
write costs an entire memory
transfer.
We have to load in a block.
But then we can fill that block
and then write out that block.
So we get to write out
B items in one step.
So we pay x to
the 1/2 because we
have to touch the last
block of this down buffer,
this down buffer,
this down buffer.
And they're x to the
1/2 down buffers.
So each one, we have to pay 1.
That's this part.
That's the expensive part.
But then, once we're
actually writing items,
if we stay here for a while,
that's basically for free.
Overall, we're writing x items.
And so to write them all will
only take x over B ceiling,
sort of, over the
entire summation.
But we have to pay 1 to start
out here, here, and here.
So this is the real
amount of time.
And I want to amortize
that, essentially.
So there's two cases now.
If x is greater than or equal
to B squared, then we're happy.
x is greater than or
equal to B squared,
then this term dominates.
And so this is tinier.
All right.
Say, x is B cubed, then
this is x to the 3/2--
sorry, this is the B to the 3/2.
This is B squared,
so this is bigger.
And so then the cost
is just x over B.
And we're done, because
we needed to prove
it's x over B times log.
We had to do this to sort, but
this distribution will be free.
Now that says all the
high levels are free.
All the low levels are free.
If you're less than B
squared, then your less than M
and you're free.
It's saying, if you're bigger
than B squared, you're free.
But there's going to be one
level right in between where
you're not really
bigger or smaller.
So there's one level where it's
going to B to the 4/3 less than
or equal to x less than
or equal to B squared,
strictly less than.
Because you're jumping in
this doubly exponential way,
you might miss slightly.
And so you're in between
these two levels.
Why is this?
Because we only know that x
to the 3/2 is less than M.
We don't know that
x is less than M.
So we have a bit of slot there.
So then at this transition
point, what we do
is say, OK, we can't afford
to store this whole-- x to 3/2
is not less than M.
So we can't afford
to store all this in the cache.
But we can afford to store
the last block of this guy
and the last block
of this guy, all the
down buffers we can store
the last block in cache.
Why?
Because there's only
x to the 1/2 of them.
And we know that x is
less than B squared.
So if x is less than B
squared, x to the 1/2
is less than B, which
is less than M over B
because M is least B squared,
by tall cache assumption.
So this is the number of blocks
that we can afford in cache.
This is number of
blocks we want.
I want 1 block
for each of these.
So basically then,
this x to the one half
term disappears for the
one transition level.
So this is free.
Because you can afford 1 block
per down buffer in cache.
And so, again, we
get an x over B cost.
So the distribution
is basically free.
The hard part is the sorting.
And then the idea
is that, well, OK--
now this is one push.
When we do an insert, that item
might get pushed many times,
but basically can only
get pushed once per level.
So you end up taking this cost
and summing it over all x.
So if you look at an insertion,
amortize what you pay--
or you look at the sum
over all these things.
You get the sorting bound
on x-- summed over x where x
is growing doubly exponential.
And so this becomes a
geometric series, or even
super geometric.
And so you get--
I guess I should look
at it per element.
You look at the amortized
cost per element,
so I get to divide by x.
Because when I do a
push, I push x elements.
So I get to divide by x, here.
And then if an element
gets pushed to all levels,
I have to sum over
all these x's.
But you do this summation
and you get order--
it's dominated by the last term.
Sorry, this should be N.
This is the fun part.
We're taking logs, here,
but conveniently this
was doubly exponential
growing, the x over B.
So when we sum these
is singly exponential.
So it's a geometric series.
And so we are just dominated
by the last term, which
is where we get log base
M over B of N over B.
And this is our amortized
cost per insertion.
Deletions are
basically the same.
You just two pulls
instead of pushes.
And you have, sort of, the
reverse of a distribution
step-- in some
ways, even simpler.
You don't have to do
this clever analysis.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Can you
explain, once again,
how is it that you got the
distributed cost of x over B?
So I understand
that every time, you
need to pay that x to the
1/2 because you need to load.
But where did the x over B come?
ERIK DEMAINE: This
is essentially
amortized per element.
We're just paying 1 over B.
Once the block has been loaded--
it's only after we
insert B items that we
have to load another item.
So that's why it's
x over B, here.
Good.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Which buffers do
we keep sorted at all times?
ERIK DEMAINE: Which buffer--
AUDIENCE: Which buffers
do we keep sorted?
ERIK DEMAINE: We're only going
to keep the very bottom buffer
sorted at all times.
So I mean, it doesn't
really matter.
You don't even have
to keep those sorted,
because you can afford
to look at all of them.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I
think the upper levels when
we're trying to figure
out where it goes?
ERIK DEMAINE: What we do
need-- we don't need them
in sorted order.
But we need to know
where the max is, yeah.
So I guess, maybe, maintain
a linked list of the items
would be one way to do it.
So the sort order is in there,
but they're not physically
stored in sorted order.
That would be a little bit
too much to hope for, I think.
Yeah.
We do need to keep
track of the max,
but that's easy to do
as you're inserting.
Cool.
So that's priority queues.
You can look at the
notes for deletions.